all right well we begin this morning
with a new and disturbing report on the
effects of global climate change a
long-awaited report called the National
Climate Assessment was released Friday
it paints a dire picture warning that
the Earth's climate is changing rapidly
primarily due to human activity the
report was compiled by more than a dozen
federal agencies and mandated by
Congress it finds climate change is
already causing more frequent and severe
storms floods wildfires and tornadoes
all of it totaling nearly four hundred
billion dollars worth of damage in just
the last three years but the findings
are at odds with many of the policies
set forth by the Trump administration we
Jiujiang is traveling with the president
in Florida we Joe good morning good
morning everybody the White House is
dismissing the report saying it is based
on the most extreme climate change
scenario and does not give enough weight
to how technology and innovation are
decreasing emissions the pushback falls
right in line with what we have long
heard from President Trump about global
warming suggesting it's fake news the
report by 13 federal agencies ominously
lays out how climate change will have a
catastrophic impact on the US economy
Americans health and the environment
the report predicts the impacts of
climate change are intensifying across
the country and climate related threats
to Americans physical social and
economic well-being are rising
researchers say global warming is
already to blame for more frequent and
destructive hurricanes and
uncontrollable wildfires the report
states if greenhouse gases continue to
rise the country will see labor related
losses of 150 billion dollars a year by
2090 damage to coastal property due to
the rise in sea levels and storm surges
could reach nearly 120 billion dollars a
year but President Trump's policies and
rhetoric often reject climate change his
administration has rolled back Obama era
environmental regulations and promoted
the production of fossil fuels we're
getting out in June 2017 the president
pulled the u.s. out of the Paris
agreement a pact of nearly 200 countries
to curb climate change mr. Trump has
often referred to global warming as a
hoax invented by China and last month
dismissed it on 60 minutes but what
about scientists who say it's worse than
ever
you'd have to show me the scientists
because they have a very big political
agenda and following this week's
unseasonal north east cold snap the
president tweeted brutal an extended
cold blast could shatter all records
whatever happened to global warming
former vice president and
environmentalist Al Gore said the
president may try to hide the truth but
his own scientists and experts have made
it as stark and clear as possible o Gore
and many others have also pointed out
the timing of the reports release he has
blamed the Trump administration for
trying to bury at the day right after
Thanksgiving and the busiest shopping
day of the year President Trump himself
has yet to weigh in on the dire findings
Michelle a lot of criticism over that
fact indeed we do Jang with the
president in Florida thank you